[موسيقى]
الزلازل والهزات الارضيه والبراكين تحدث
في كل ثانيه تمر لكن اغلبها خفيف لا يحس
بها البشر فالبراكين لا تحدث الا في
اماكنها والزلازل لا تحدث الا في احزمتها
فلزلازل احزمه تحيط بالكره الارضيه احاطت
السواري بل معصم اخطرها حزام النار والذي
يمر على جنوب شرق اسيا وعلى ايران وعلى
تركيا والحزام الثانوي والذي يمر على بعضا
من الدول العربيه وبلدان الخليج بعيده كل
البعد عن الاحزمه الزلزاليه فلا يحدث فيها
زلزال ذوبال ولا يثور فيها بركان عال
وللزلازل درجات اقل من درجتين يحس بها
الحيوان اقل من ثلاث درجات يحس بها
الاجهزه اقل من اربع درجات يحس بعض البشر
اقل من خمس درجات تحدث اضرارا اقل من ست
درجات تحدث اضرار لمسافه 160 كيلو من مركز
الزلزال اذا زادت عن سبع درجات
تطرح الدنيا وتهلك الدنيا باضرارها اطرح
الدنيا فمن عاداتها تخفض العالي وتعلي من
سفل عيشه الراغب في تحصيلها عيشه الجاهل
فيها ام اقل
[موسيقى]